[Music]
and was it worth it yes maybe I know
submitted by Julio Oh a nurse is fired
after being connected to an outrageous
statement posted on Twitter what did she
say how bad could it really [ __ ] in your
[ __ ] medicine cup you know
there's a Netflix show where they talk
about [ __ ] uh what's it called like
[ __ ] nurses and [ __ ] that are [ __ ]
killing people and stuff on purpose
about purpose just so they could go
higher in rank so what would they do
right they would like [ __ ] them up on
purpose and then they'll be like the
reason be like eh
I found that out of [ __ ] also they [ __ ]
off on purpose and then they're like all
Shia found out why it is and it's
because of me they're like better but
they were doing like so many times there
was like a trend and [ __ ] and they will
find out and [ __ ] what happened is this
a documentary it's not necklace yeah I
kept my brother Tony Bassett all like
all of all of her patients were getting
hepatitis cuz she kept [ __ ] in their
food [ __ ] like what with you in shooting
I don't know how to make someone
diseased outside of shitty outside of
shooting or cyanide you know no I
remember hearing about this one nurse
that she kept like for a couple decades
she kept intentionally killing these
babies that were in the NICU and like
she had like this thing it's something
mental where like they want to feel like
the hero but like so she causes the
thing and so she would try to save these
babies in a lot of the time they would
die but then like that's stupid
so she'll break the phone and be like oh
phone tech to the rescue oh if they save
them no but this nurse yeah if it's this
the black nurse yeah you know about this
dog asada histogram so this nurse her
name was Tysha Baker
sure except the hospital or she recently
got hired at this one hospital for in
Indiana University Health yeah and so
they found this tweet she tweeted every
white woman raises a detriment to
society when they are when they raise a
son someone with the highest propensity
to be a terrorist rapists race
and domestic violence all-star
historically every son you had should be
sacrificed to the Wolves [ __ ] she's
been watching too much news while she's
really angry won't you say that she's
not right because the news makes white
males look horrible
just like they make every minority look
horrible you know it's because of the
news that you think like all Asians are
always smuggling people and eating dogs
you know the news aren't news are like
these mass shooters are all all white
boys or entertainment - like the movies
and stuff they just give you that idea
yeah she's she's been watching she needs
to get off of watching [ __ ] and read
something you blame a baby babies don't
do nothing wrong they're just babies man
[Music]
she looked like a young Erykah Badu
she's got nice lips she doesn't come off
as the person that would say such a
demonic thing burn the baby even if you
felt that you would think someone in
health care would be able to say that in
the warm compassionate way you know the
trip tears she's a nurse in Pediatrics
oh no she probably killing white babies
yeah oh my god baby's not innocent
well since she was a new hire at this
particular Health System they're saying
that she wasn't dealing with patients
yet she was still in via thank goodness
you know like still training and stuff
why did she say that statement did she
go through a bad experience or was she
just venting I don't know I I couldn't
find anything that like any reports
coming from her like any statements from
her did a white guy at Starbucks mess up
her coffee order or something like that
no no I really I don't know why she
would say something like that but
because of her saying that though now
it's led to her termination so of course
you're not stable enough to take care of
babies mm-hmm
come on now those precious bundles of
joy yeah cause like I would say kill a
lot of people but I never target the
babies man she said you don't target the
baby you got a little weight and let
them [ __ ] make mistakes and then you
go you pedophile you can't you can't be
like hey baby you a pedophile I'm gonna
kill you
well you know that
that that like common question that if
you can travel back in time and kill
Hitler has a baby no no you just raise
them differently I just choose that
their travel back in time and then take
him to our time there you go yeah you're
pretty much good but you just got no
Hitler just got this little German baby
with the word mustache yeah or someone
you've done the exact same thing he did
somebody gotta be the devil why did why
did Hitler one blond-haired blue-eyed
people when he wasn't blonde and
blue-eyed
I don't know family members or something
that were Jewish really no I think he
was Jewish or part like his mom side or
something right yeah oh [ __ ] no I
know nothing about this direction oh he
had that cute mustache cute now yeah a
little Charlie Chaplin in that's cute
well Charlie Chaplin thing going on yeah
I mean little so there's no reason or
anything she didn't make a statement she
just like talking mad [ __ ] and she got
fired yeah I really couldn't find any
statements from her like reasoning as to
why she would say something that it's
just a lot of the reports are stating
what I stated which is the fact that she
tweeted this out and then now the
hospital like the system where she works
in or worked and they did have a
statement saying that they were aware
and that the HR department was gonna be
investigating that and during that time
of an investigation she would not have
any access to patient care but then now
it's come out that she just got fired
that's pretty nuts how we we put our
hands and so many like we entrust our
lives and so many strangers ends yeah
it's [ __ ] scary if you think about it
really it's really scary I don't trust
nobody just kidding just kidding if
there's a somebody that's not named dr.
Mike okay
[ __ ] look at my butthole do whatever
you want I don't care just I just
[ __ ] relax it's like all about but
you're about [ __ ] but right now no
it's a it's a special place you don't
let me you don't let anybody [ __ ]
into your special place like like like
balls my special place is right here
yeah
it's my heart clavicle debajo is very
special okay the mouth is also very
special and then your [ __ ] ball sacks
and all those things are very special
anybody was weird skin is special and
when you need somebody to heal you when
you go to the healers office
everything is hey I'm a [ __ ] science
specimen just look at me just look at
everything I don't I don't feel that
like shame anymore I just you need to
[ __ ] lift my balls and [ __ ] look
please look at it please fix me coz when
you got diarrhea when you feelin like
[ __ ] when you feelin like garbage I
don't have time for shame just do
whatever you got to do you don't shame
right now either I get a little bashful
[Laughter]
mule you know when I'm when I got a
really P and then like I don't know
people to look [ __ ] liar I know shut
up shut the [ __ ] up yeah you know in
France people were peeing at the street
I will never do that like there was all
these drunk guys just ripping their dick
out peeing and then the trees would be
like those new trees where it's like
this then their dick but they're
standing like to the side and they're
pink yeah it's like what the [ __ ] no
shame I would never do that I'm a
bashful guy I'd at least [ __ ] turn
around and then like wait wait the guy
that has a [ __ ] video of him in a
bikini with his pubes hanging out on
YouTube is a [ __ ] bashful guy yeah
because I have self-respect I'm not
fully nude that's why your pubes were
all over my [ __ ] bikini that I lent
you guys yeah that was your bikini I
read that I no longer own those bikini
okay
did you wear them again No Oh what was
it once I saw that I was like I'm done
like retired in the
you know I can't believe you Bart I
would have just bought like 99 cents we
were on a budget Carl he 9ss or bikinis
just came out exist how much do
meat-tinis cost I'll do there they could
be really dirty each yeah like each I
don't even know why you're spending like
a million dollars on [ __ ] tooth floss
what the [ __ ] is the fabric is not that
much what the [ __ ] is going in and now
that the trend was having all your ass
cheeks out like it's like a thong thank
you God
like that's awesome it's [ __ ] bad
tactic you know what I like about that
less fabric now you know what's awesome
about that
so like the thing is most girls don't
want to be the first to do it cuz you
will help but if everybody's doing it
and you're the one wearing granny bikini
then you're the weird one I love you're
only thinking of the hot hats when
they're not the hot hot sand they're
just kind of the below averages then
you're kind of like oh but it still
gives you something to look at you know
I mean if all if I was a high school
student now do you guys have so much
more things to look at dude well they
also have porn in the fingertips like ah
but that stuff is like still digital I'm
talking about in person it's like right
there
when I was at what I was going to I was
in the area where they had like the arc
arena in Sacramento there's a 24-hour
there there was a girl that walked in
the t-mobile and all of a stop and we
were just like what color her vents they
were gray with a little pink on it oh
yeah it was like really tight I just
didn't expect it and I just it was a
treat gray white ten look any those like
soft colors yeah it was literally one of
those moments woman oh she's really
pretty
God did you tell Mary oh that story huh
no no I absolutely did not
[Music]